hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to papers please i just
ate some spicy jalapenos
so i'm going to be dealing with this
while i get back into dealing with this
i'm fine okay 60 credits four family
members one token apartment sure
i don't know hey uh
theft was that was i dealing with that
already i can't remember where i was
it doesn't matter december 3rd i think
it did
go back enough in time i think i just
touched my eyeballs with my pinot hands
[Laughter]
don't ask me why jalapenos i just have
pickled jalapenos and i was like
that'll be a good snack right before i
start recording and it wasn't
okay i need stephanopoulos stefani
stefani greyer and mikhail sarto stefani
and mikhail i gotta actually be on the
lookout for these people
okay i gotta look at uh
i keep touching my eyes with my pinot
fingers
ah i should have just ah i don't have
any milk i've got cream
i don't want to pour myself a glass of
cream but i'm debating pouring myself a
glass of cream
i gotta hang out i'll be back
[Music]
okay so i have hot chocolate um i don't
know how i cocked up hot chocolate but i
messed it up bad i had cream but i also
had hot chocolate
but it's not like i have a kitchen i
just have a hot water kettle so i was
like
okay i'll just put the cream with the
hot chocolate powder
and mix that up turns out it doesn't
really mix well in just pure cream and
this is coffee cream maybe the reason
that it's not mixing is because it's
cold
so i started spraying the side of the
mug with like
hot water and that didn't work that just
ended up spraying water everywhere and
i was holding the cup so the water was
like hot water was like spraying on my
hand
that hurt
hey and the crazy thing is by the time i
got all this stuff my tongue is not
you know the heat from the penis isn't
really bothering me anymore
this is a hell of a way to start a
start-up episode okay so we got
stephanie greyer
stefani greyer mikhail sarantov
sarentoff
next come on in it's okay
all right we're doing this hey how you
doing give me papers
all right what is this this matches
dates good day it's good
oberston lauren does
two months name's good all right this
looks good
oh there's no trouble what
oh god no god i'm [ __ ]
right the whole thing about the hold on
everybody hold on
oh my god just please dear
okay we just crashed this is going great
you are doing nothing
okay i think we're working again
okay let's make this happen stefani
greyer
mikhail saratov i've got it locked in
everybody
i know exactly what i'm doing and when
i'm doing it hello
oh look at this forgery
get out of here oh i should detain you
though wait a minute
yes yeah uh-huh
don't know anything about that too bad
get out of here
forgeries will not be tolerated i'm
gonna get paid for that one
hey it's my buddies my bro my guy
this all looks so you know what i'm not
even going to question it
[Music]
there you go buddy have a good day
i know thanks pal
thank you appreciate that big big
oh yeah he's gonna pay me that's right
hey bud yeah okay uh-huh sure thing
whatever you say man
okay ah mikhail saratov mikhail
saratov okay you know what i'm just
gonna let you go through
you go ahead the order rises the order
rises it sure does buddy
it sure does
okay it's publia
outer gross well that's not right this
is not right at all
here we go hey what's up this all about
what's this all about too bad
goodbye bud goodbye you're going to be
more money for me
okay pictures good date of birth matches
height 170. wait
what are you carrying on you what do you
got on you what do you got on you buddy
what do you got on you what do you got
[Music]
hmm oh my god jesus christ
okay well that's a problem
uh we gonna talk about that
if those are explosives kind of lucky
that he doesn't just set him off while
he's here
hello you're probably fine
uh 172 61
date of birth matches up let's see sane
marm
what the heck no that doesn't make any
sense
that doesn't make any sense this is
false
too bad get out of here look i got a
sharp eye for these kind of things
you cannot get away from me a strange
man brought money unchecked to burn it
this seems like obviously one of those
things where it would definitely lead to
someone finding me that i had the money
but to be perfectly honest a thousand
dollars hey
what did i do you know well i did i just
let some dude in
i've done it was a mistake a common
mistake easy i'm not gonna burn it oh
grestin metro halted tunnel cave and
hints at sabotage
oops not my problem not my problem my
dudes
not my problem my dudes not my problem
hi
holy hell hi i'm healthy yes
a few questions for me sure
uh let's just uh
let me just there you go buddy
we think some members pass through this
checkpoint so we come to talk to you
[Music]
have you seen anything like this like
what
no i have not uh yes
yes very good
could i give this i could give this but
i won't
there you go buddy there you go pal this
group is very dangerous
if you see anything curious report it
immediately oh i will
i will pal i will
all right let's do this i have so much
money i have so much money i'm so happy
with all the money i have i have so much
money
hey what's up i can take my time now oh
nice
yeah job but you do yeah stay weeks okay
that's
great that's great united federation
great rapid that works out
oh yeah xm988 rachel oh oh
we got a little bit of an issue here we
got a little bit of an issue
you have multiple names all right well
we'll we'll go through it we'll go
through it we'll go through the process
that's what we're here for that's what
we're here for
okay all right rachel hill and everbook
at lada these do match up these do match
up you know what you're right about that
you're
good to go hey good job thanks for being
you
thanks for being here you have a good
day now have a wonderful day you have a
wonderful day now take care take care
take care now
hey what's up bud welcome home bro
welcome home
this all matches up yeah this all
matches up
this all matches up yeah this is looking
good this is looking good
you know this is looking good my dude
date earth matches up
this looks good orrick vanor that
matches up
the vashillo district this all looks
good my dude this all looks great
actually
you see many people yes i'm looking for
engineers do me a favor
give my card to any engineers you meet
come back in a few days pay five
for each that calls me oh okay well
that's easy enough
okay engineers doesn't even seem illegal
hello are you an engineer
okay east creston that works out date of
birth matches
expiration is good all this looks good
you know this looks great
good stuff here hey thanks so much you
an engineer
all right fine but what what invalid hi
go away i'm not in the mood
no engineering huh interesting take one
of these
[Music]
what is this huh
yep well it only works if you go through
but it does look like you're good to go
hey noblehead noblehead noble all things
match up here
this is all good my dude take it and be
well do you like my plaque
do you like my plaque do you like my
plaque do you like my plaque
it's a good plaque whatever
hi
i mean it looks good oh no
no no kalechia again
kalechia again kalechia again
a class 70 a class 7 apartment is
available
you know what why don't we splurge a
little
my family why don't we splurge a little
bit huh oh yeah we deserve it
another bomber slips through immigrant
screening falls short moa gets new
director
stricter protocol is promised at the
border yeah well you know
you know how it is you know
you know you know new director is
unsatisfied with level of scrutiny
forward to foreigners from today
forward all foreigners entrance must
present a recent identity supplement
listing weight height and appearance
all right let's just go for it
oh here we go okay
height let's see a few weeks will it now
oh my god so much i need to check
through okay republia boston that's good
dates good dates good um expiration is
okay
killer sideburns killer sideburns
you know what you got you got that right
buddy oddly enough this looks okay
weirdly i can't i can't believe it but
it actually looks okay
i might have missed something but who
knows oh
here we go with this dude hey what's up
what do you need you giving me
i money i did detain five people yep
thank you thank you pal there's more
from last time
this is all i have now soon i make up
the rest yeah sure you will
i'm sure you will buddy sure you will
hey what's up passing through huh
okay name good
that's good dates good integria glorion
that's good
name's good let's get you glasses 79 177
that's about right that's about right
yeah you look good oddly enough we've
been getting some goods
you know maybe the maybe the number of
restrictions is actually keeping people
from
trying to play the system a little bit
so wait the seal the seal the seal the
seal the seal the seal the seal
god
the seal i saw that last goddamn second
all right oh engineer here take this
they're hiring yes they
are okay dates good import hey han
numbers are good name is good yeah all
looks good to me all looks good wait
wait wait wait a minute what is this
wavy hair i'm not seeing wavy hair okay
it's wavy here
all right hey you take your four goddamn
pieces of paper and you get the hell out
of my booth
okay have a good day cause no trouble
all right hello
how you doing buddy okay wait you know
what's going on you put on a few pounds
what's going on what's up here what's up
buddy
what's going on hal
no look at this what is this how do you
explain this to yourself
how do you explain this to me how do you
explain anything
get out all right come on in
okay what do we have here let's see
transit
yeah uh-huh this looks good
bobbed hair what's going on here well
it's not really
bobbed but whatever wherever you say get
out of here
get out of here get the hell out of here
[Music]
incorrect visit duration response
whatever whatever who cares what they
say
shut up okay
screw it just go just get out of here i
don't even care anymore
i don't even care go get gone get going
oh
and i'm really slipping man neighbors
have reported your new wealth the
ministry of income has confiscated your
savings pending investigation a cheaper
class a department is available
hmm well
ain't that a [ __ ] oh my god holy crap
daley bulletins will now contain a
listing of the top three most wanted
international criminals check faces
against entrance and detain suspects
immediately
okay we got some wanted criminis here
okay i gotta really make some money my
whole family is hungry and cold
um so let's go baby let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go
hey what's up oh kalechia huh kolechia
[Music]
what is this oh what is this we have
some questions for you
uh well i'm not gonna funny to see you
here just when we start looking for
criminals
the only thing i'm going to regret is
that you're not getting a bonus for this
justice for ourselves
come on in hey how are you doing oh hey
what's up oh good
this is great large gift was mistake now
investigates your connection next asian
cups today we'll solve problem deny it
own risk okay
gotcha thank you
okay vicender bald 79.
it's good dates good republish
yep that makes sense oh oh
who do we have here uh oh
uh oh you do not like my tone well i
don't like you
being not arrested we got a lot of
detainees today
all right so we're good to go we only
just got this one dude left uh-huh
okay 182.
that makes sense these are quite tall
okay it's good
great forever uniformation great rapid
but this isn't you
the years have been cruel huh well we'll
see about that
oh yeah oh yeah no this is
this is very different yes sorry goodbye
i'm gonna get a big detaination bonus
the heftiest of detonation bonuses
unless that was the name i was supposed
to
[Music]
hello okay 176 54
straight here yeah this all makes sense
two weeks transit
transit seal is good all this is good
shockingly have a good day and there's
not really much time for that
person to get through did i not get them
through did i accidentally detain them
you are not this person yes sorry
goodbye
god damn it did i i did didn't i goddamn
it i must have
i must have hang on i gotta go back okay
i'm going into this again just because i
think i
accidentally detained them i must have
right i must have
okay david oh okay here we go
all right my dude east greston that's
not that's right that is right yeah that
is right
[Music]
oh my god the seagulls the seagulls
the goals oh
stephanie gray interesting
well you know what stefanie this all
looks good anyway
you go right on ahead stephanie you go
right on ahead
you go right on head
i don't even know if i'll have time for
this
[Music]
good vision um
my dude
there you go pal your son is sick and
needs medicine
well [ __ ] well
[ __ ] well [ __ ] where's my
money oh no
oh no oh actually we're okay
hey cool it's
all good all right so i'm gonna end this
episode here
we're kind of in the thick of it but hey
i fixed all my mistakes
and i have made no mistakes everyone can
guarantee if you know i'd haven't make
any
made any mistakes put in the comments of
how i have not made any mistakes
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye
[Music]
you